PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. WE HAVE ONE BILL
ON OUR FILE TODAY AT ONE OF THE
BUT OF THE AUTHOR SENATOR GROVE
THIS IS. AS J. R. TWELVE
INTRODUCED ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH
SO. DECISION THAT HAPPENED A
LITTLE LATER IN OUR YEAR WE
WELCOME YOU TO PRESENT YOUR
YOUR BILL. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
PERSONALLY LIKE TO SAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR PULLING THIS
COMMITTEE TOGETHER I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR STAFF WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND MAKING THIS
HAPPEN. IT IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE REPRESENT MY DISTRICT IS THE
FIRST WE HAVE THE ONE TWO AND
THREE AGRICULTURE COUNTIES IN
THE ENTIRE NATION. WE FRESNO
TULARE AND KERN OBVIOUSLY
PRODUCE MORE AGRICULTURE THAN
ANY OTHER STE A COUNTIES IN THE
ENTIRE NATION SO IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT. SO OBVIOUSLY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR WORKING WITH
US AS CHAIR TWELVE CALLS ON
CONGRESS AND TO RATIFY THE
UNITED STATES AND MEXICO CANADA
AGREEMENT KNOWN AS THE US MCA.
THIS AGREEMENT BUILDS ON THE
TENETS OF THE FORMER. TRYING
NATIONAL AGREEMENT KNOWN AS
NAFTA IN ITS EXISTING
PROTECTIONS FOR AMERICAN
BUSINESS AND POLITICAL
PROPERTIES ACTUALLY INCREASE
UNDER THIS AGREEMENT. SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THE YEAR
THAT NAFTA'S RATIFICATION
AGRICULTURE EXPORTS HAS
QUADRUPLES FROM NINE BILLION TO
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
EXPORTS FROM CALIFORNIA. MY
SENATE DISTRICT LIKE I SAID HAS
THE ONE TWO AND THREE TOP
COUNTIES IN THE NATION FOR
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTION. AND
OVERALL CALIFORNIA EXPORTED
MORE THAN THIRTY POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN PRODUCTS TO
OUR SOUTHERN NEIGHBOR AND
SEVENTEEN POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS INTO OUR NORTHERN FOR.
THESE COUNTIES COMBINED MAKE UP
ABOUT 28% CALIFORNIA'S TOP
EXPORTS. WITH THE ADOPTION OF
THE USMC CALIFORNIA ALONE IS
EXPECTED INCREASED KIT EXPORTS
TO CANADA AND MEXICO BI FIVE
POINT 9% AND SIX POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. RESPECTIVELY THESE
INCREASE EXPORTS WILL INCREASE
NEARLY THIRTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN EXPORTS FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND THE CREATION OF
JOBS MORE THAN A DOZEN OTHER
STATES HAVE ON THE PASS MILLER
RESOLUTIONS CALLING ON CONGRESS
TO RATIFY THE U. S. MCA. THIS
COMMITTEE ITSELF JUST IT BACK
JULY VOTED ON S. R. FORTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR HUESO AND IT WAS
SIMILAR IN THE FACT TO S. YEAR
TWELVE BECAUSE IT RECOGNIZED.
MEXICO AS A KEY TRADE PARTNER
TO ENCOURAGE THE. IT STATES TO
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL AT A
SEPARATE AGREEMENT WITH ART
SOUTHERN NEIGHBOR. S. YOUR
TWELVE GOES FOR FARTHER BECAUSE
IT INCLUDES OUR NORTHERN
NEIGHBOR OF CANADA AND WE THINK
THERE AND EQUALLY IMPORTANT
TRADING PARTNER. CONGRESS IS
POISED TO TAKE UP THE US MCA AT
THE END OF SEPTEMBER SEVERAL
OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED THIS. MEXICO'S
PRESIDENT THE PRESENT UNITED
STATES AND THE PRIME MINISTER
OF CANADA HAVE ALREADY AGREED
TO THIS AGREEMENT. MEXICO HAS
ADOPTED THIS AGREEMENT AND WE
NEED THE OTHER TWO PARTICIPANTS
TO TAKE PLACE AND I WOULD JUST
LIKE CALIFORNIA TO ENCOURAGE
OUR CONGRESS TO DO SO. THAT'LL
TAKE QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY
I'M UP LATE PAUSE FOR JUST A
MOMENT ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
WILL CONTINUE WITH THE HEARINGS
OF THE SECTOR WOULD CALL THAT.
THE LASER HERE GLAZER HERE
CHANGE YOUR CHIANG HERE
ARCHULETA DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI HERE HILL. SO HERE
LEYVA PAN WILK RESIDENTS WILL
CARE OKAY SO WE HAVE A QUORUM.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FIRST
ANYBODY ELSE HERE WANT TO SHARE
THEIR THOUGHTS. I ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SO LET'S BRING
THE MATTER BACK O THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COLLEAGUES. THERE'S NOT. LET ME
AT FIRST THANK YOU FOR. THE
WORK THAT CENTER YOU HAVE DONE
TO BRING THIS. ISSUE TO US I
KNOW YOUR STATS WORKED ON IT MY
STAFF HAS HAD A LOT OF TIME BUT
THE IN HOUSE THIS WAS PREPARED
ON IT. AND I KNOW FOR ME. IT'S
A PRETTY COMPLICATED SUBJECT
WHEN YOU GET INTO IT. AND
OBVIOUSLY IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
BEEN. WORKED ON FOR A LONG
TIME. I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THAT YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ALLOW THE SENATE TO HEAR THIS.
THIS ISSUE I NOTED THAT THE
WITH THE LATER DIRECTION OF THE
BILL. AUGUST FOURTEENTH IN THE
FACT THAT IT WASN'T SET FOR
HEARING. IN THIS COMMITTEE
UNTIL JUST A MATTER OF HOURS
AGO. THAT WE HAVEN'T REALLY
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY THAT I
KNOW WE WOULD ALL LIKE FOR
OTHERS WHO HAVE INTEREST IN
THIS TO SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS.
AND SO MY THINKING WOULD BE
THAT. AT AS A RESPECT FOR YOU
THAT IT WOULD BE A- VALUABLE
THING TO MOVE THIS. RESOLUTION
TO THE FLOOR. AND CAN GIVE
YOURSELF THE CHANCE TO. ALL OF
US THE CHANCE TO DIVE INTO THE
ISSUE IN MORE DETAIL. I THINK
THAT WOULD. AND SO FOR TODAY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT. MOVING THAT
BILL FORWARD THANK YOU SIR I
WOULD NOTE THAT THERE. THERE
ARE MANY THINGS THAT. OUR
PRESIDENT OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT
SAYS AND DOES THAT I'M NOT VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF. AND SO THE THESE
TYPES OF A GOOD THINGS THAT HE
HAS. WORKED ON BEHALF OF OUR
COUNTRY. FIVE AT. AT REQUIRE I
THINK IT ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY
THESE FROM MY POINT OF VIEW.
AND THAT MY VOTE TODAY IS NOT
AN ENDORSEMENT NECESSARILY OF.
WHAT HE IS PUT ON THE TABLE I
WANTED I WANT THE TIME TO
ACTUALLY EXAMINE IT MORE
CAREFULLY. BUT I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR RESOLUTION TODAY
THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CAN I GET
A MOTION ON THAT. I WILL BILL
BUT- ALSO WANTED TO COMMENT
THAT. I'M NOT AS FAMILIAR WITH
ALL OF THE DETAILS THAT I WOULD
WANT TO BE BUT I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE AND WHILE. WE MAY
DISAGREE WITH THE PRESENT ON
SOME THINGS. WHEN HE IS DOING
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
IMPROVE. THE ECONOMIC CLIMATE
FOR CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY
WITH RELATION TO AGRICULTURE. I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE PART
OF THAT DISCUSSION AND WE NEED
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF GETTING TO
THE SAME AND SELF. I THANK THE
CHAIR. AND WILL MAKE A MOTION.
OKAY MA'AM BEFORE I RECOGNIZE
THAT MOTION ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
IF NOT. CENTER GALGIANI IS AS
MOVE THIS. RESOLUTION WITH THAT
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO BE ADOPTED AND TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. GLAZER AYE
GLAZER AYE CHIANG CHEN AYE
ARCHULETA. DODD ALL RIGHT DODD
NAY GALGIANI GUARDIAN AND I
HILL HILL AYE. LEYVA HAND WILK
HI WILL GUY. BUT AB AT BUT THAT
MEASURE ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
POPULAR BUT HONESTLY WHEN THEY
ARE. DO I THINK ABOUT ENDING UP
.
HI WE'RE GONNA CALL THE AYE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC COMMITTEE BACK TO
ORDER I'M INFORMED THAT ARE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARE UNLIKELY TO.
BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS HEARING
AGAIN OF A SCHEDULED LATE
PRITCHETT THE COURTESIES OF
OTHER MEMBERS WHO WERE ABLE TO
GET HERE BUT NO THAT SOMEONE
ABLE TO CHANGE THEIR PLANS SO
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE
ROLE ON AS J. R. TWELVE IT GETS
OUT SIX TWO ZERO. AND WITH THAT
TO AT THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED